[Musique]
Isor Viron a tout quitter pour consacrer
une vie entière à la restauration de son
château familial le château de Troussay
est considéré comme l'un des plus petits
châteaux de la Loire et pourtant les
tâches quotidiennes s'avèrent être sans
fin rencontre avec Isor
du Val de Loire c'est-à-dire qu'on a des
cloches tombes comme à Chambord de même
que les cheminées incrustations
d'ardoise la Vierge au centre elle vient
de Cheverny la porte est inspirée d'une
porte de Chenonceau et à droite une
porte qui vient du château de Donzy à
l'intérieur c'est pareil
on y va vite va très vite soyez accroché
je vous le dis
voilà j'ai le grand honneur de découvrir
le salon du Château de troussaye qui ont
travaillé entretenir un château c'est du
temps c'est de l'énergie pourquoi ce
choix ça me donne plein de métiers
polyvalents et amusant en fait tu
t'occupes aussi bien de l'extérieur que
du marketing que des travaux je sais que
tu as fait quand même beaucoup
d'émissions de télé grâce au château de
Troussay mais là le chat il valide la
mienne il est venu direct il s'est posé
moi je m'incruste Camille je rate pas ça
ouais on y va
en fait c'était le cabinet de travail de
mon arrière-grand-père demain quand les
gens pourront découvrir redécouvrir le
château de TROUSSEY toi mis ta pierre à
l'édifice bah en fait tu partages tu
partages déjà et puis tu fais en sorte
que
en fait que ça vive et c'est pour ça que
le château en fait te donne une énergie
c'est nous qui partageons en partageant
cette énergie pour faire que le château
t'apporte en fait une sensation une
impression de bien-être transmet quelque
chose de heureux ou pas
le ronronnement
la chapelle c'est une pièce que j'aime
bien alors viens
[Musique]
un escalier comme ça franchement dans un
château tu es obligé de tester c'est
extraordinaire alors il apporte alors la
porte elle est incroyable elle était au
trésorier du roi elle est partie au
Japon en 72 pour une exposition Val de
Loire séjour des rois où elle a fait
l'admiration de tout le monde notamment
des souverains et elle est vraiment
considérée comme une des plus belles
portes de la Renaissance en France
je vais te présenter mon frère
[Musique]
Venezuela Mexique Argentine je suis
désolé apprends-moi des pas de danse
salsa bachata merengue est-ce que tu
veux je suis chaud ouais mais alors
après qu'on ait mis la table des 12
personnes on y va d'accord
[Musique]